over the past decade we've seen a
drastic change in the types of traffic
patterns that application developers
have to plan for one day you could be at
standard traffic and the next needing to
scale to handle tens of thousands more
visitors this of course leads to all
sorts of issues with cost response times
and scale and there's no place in your
application where this is felt more than
in your database whether it's dealing
with scale or just struggling to fit
unstructured data into a relational
schema design most relational databases
struggle to solve these issues this is
where Couchbase comes in as a highly
scalable high-performance no SQL
document database Couchbase is one of
the fastest new SQL databases available
entirely designed with modern
applications in mind and right now
there's nothing more modern than running
a database using kubernetes see
kubernetes has rapidly increased in
sophistication with things like
operators persistent volumes helping
developers transition to the cloud and
scale where they need to this is why
we've built a special kubernetes
operator called the Couchbase autonomous
operator and it gives you the ability to
deploy multi node clusters by writing a
small configuration and pushing it to
kubernetes recovering automatically from
node failures automatically scaling your
cluster up or down as load from the
application changes ensuring that nodes
in the cluster are evenly split across
racks or zones in the data center
you can also automatically upgrade the
cluster to a newer version of Couchbase
server and manage cluster configuration
to ensure that the configuration is
properly set in your cluster and to help
bring this power to you without all the
headaches we've teamed up with the GCP
marketplace to make deploying and
managing Couchbase completely automated
let's take a quick look at how easy it
is to setup a cowfish cluster on gke
using the Couchbase autonomous operator
through the GCP marketplace the first
thing you need to do is log into GCP and
navigate to the google kubernetes engine
then click the applications link to get
to the applications marketplace click
deploy from the marketplace and then
scroll down to get to the Couchbase
autonomous operator click the configure
button to configure a new operator and
then make sure that the operator is
going to be installed into the correct
cluster in our case standard cluster 1
and click deploy it'll take a few
moments to actually deploy the operator
but once it's done you should get to
screen that looks like this this means
that the Couchbase operator has been
successfully deployed and that you can
now move forward to creating your first
Couchbase question the next thing that
you need to do is define a configuration
for your first Couchbase cluster that
you want to create in this example we
create a three node cluster with the
data index and query service one bucket
named default then we're running a
Couchbase enterprise 5.5 bit to push
this configuration to your kubernetes
cluster and the operator will
automatically start creating a new
cowfish cluster based on the
specification that we just defined after
a few minutes you should see that your
Couchbase cluster is created and you
have access to the Couchbase
administration console if you click on
the server's button you'll see that we
have a three node cluster created and if
you click on the buckets tab you'll see
that we have a default bucket just by
running a few commands we can use the
Couchbase operator to deploy the cluster
for us if any of our Couchbase notes
fail then the operator will get the
Couchbase cluster back into a healthy
state if we need to upgrade the cluster
to a later version in the future and we
can have the operator take care of the
upgrade for us
we aim to make management of Couchbase
clusters a thing of the past an envision
a world where users no longer need to
focus on managing their infrastructure
and can spend all their time building
their applications and when it comes to
running the Couchbase autonomous
operator on Google's gke
it just works visit the GCP marketplace
today to set up a Couchbase cluster on
gke or visit the link below to learn
more
[Music]